Let's be honest. This is not the best year to say Merry Christmas.
Many of you will have empty chairs of the table this year.
Others like me couldn't even make it home for the holidays.
And every one of us in one way or another,
we'll celebrate a better sweet end to 2020.
But despite all of this,
this is still Christmas attain to faint optimism,
even when it seems impossible. And this is why no matter what this year,
we want to offer you some good news as a Christmas treat,
let's get started.
It's midnight on 4th of November, 2020,
just a few hours after voting closed on the elections,
that would ultimately cost him the oval office. Us president,
Donald Trump managed to see one of his great commitments fulfilled the
withdrawal of the United States from the so-called Paris agreement.
The American power fastest associated itself from one of the most important
global agreements ever reached to give you an idea at the time of making this
video,
196 countries had signed this agreement and 188 more had ratified
it throughout the world.
The Paris agreement was first adopted at the Paris climate conference cop 21 on
12th of December, 2015.
In this agreement,
the signatory countries essentially committed themselves to reducing their
greenhouse gas emissions. But take note,
because this was the great novelty they did.
So by accepting the duty of having to present concrete plans on how they
intended to comply with their negotiated objectives, not only that,
but the obligation for all member countries to report periodically on their
emissions and efforts to carry out their plans was also incorporated into the
agreement. In other words,
the Paris agreement sorts to go far beyond a mere declaration of India,
But now United States,
the second most polluting country after China has decided to abandon the
agreement,
although it will be somewhat temporary because Joe Biden has already stated his
intention to return.
Join us.
The thing is that this tubing and fro-ing has made us here at visual politic,
ask ourselves a few questions. What does this agreement entail?
Or rather what hope is there that its goals will actually be met to answer these
questions.
We have decided to take a look at how things stand in the activity that accounts
through around three quarters. That's almost 75% of all CO2 emissions.
I'm talking about power generation, but what other sources of energy,
electricity, heat, and combustion on which the whole world economy is based.
How have these sources changed over the last few years?
How is energy changing and why what's could the departure of the United States
from the Paris agreement mean for the rest of the world?
Difference in this video,
we're going to see how many of the preconceived ideas we will have are in one
way or another wrong.
I think many of you are going to be quite surprised by a lot of the things we're
going to tell you today.
Are you ready to look inside the great engine of the world and see how it's
changing? Well, let's get started.
[Inaudible].
Energy consumption has three main forms, electricity, transportation,
and heat generation together.
They account for almost three quarters of all carbon dioxide.
Michigan's because.
Is that today, the engine that keeps the world moving runs on dirty energy,
fossil fuels,
coal oil and gas accounts for 79% of our global energy production.
So far, I doubt that any of this is surprising to any of you. However,
hold on a moment,
because during the last few years there have been two very pronounced trends on
the one hand, although its consumption increased slightly in absolute terms,
the importance of coal in the world's energy supply has decreased over the last
decade. A decade that began with very high expectations for this fuel.
You see the decades that began in the year 2000 saw the greatest growth in
demand for coal in history.
The economic takeoff of China whose energy network is mainly fed by coal.
The Asian giant is responsible for almost half of all the world's coal
production meant that during those 10 years,
the demand for this fuel grew more than during the previous four decades
combined at the beginning of this century,
everything pointed to the fact that China's unstoppable economic growth together
with the budding takeoff of India.
Another country addicted to coal would also boost coal consumption over the
following decade. However, this did not happen between 2010 and 2019.
The trend for coal demand was not positive. And in fact, in 2019,
the demand for coal was lower than it had been in 2013.
The growing environmental concerns represented by the Paris agreement itself.
Along with the natural gas revolution in the United States,
brought on as a consequence of fracking,
which released huge amounts of natural gas and caused prices to plummet sank.
The us giants called consumption by 40%.
This by the way was excellent news.
The decrease in the use of coal explained 75% of the reduction in CO2 emissions
that the United States registered between 2005 and 2017. And then in Europe,
something similar happened,
Environmental awareness, lover, gas prices, new liquified,
natural gas capabilities and the new emissions trading scheme.
Pause the share of coal in power generation to sink by 50%.
Wait a minute because the emergence of gas was by no means the only reason for
the drop in the use of coal. What is certain is that during the last decade,
we have witnessed the beginning of a whole revolution that over renewable
energies, particularly wind and solar energy. Do you want an example?
The global of photo-voltaic solar energy has increased almost 20
times during the last decade.
We are talking about the shift that not even the Corona virus has managed to
stop Facts,
to give you an idea.
The international energy agency estimates that by the end of 2020 world energy
demand will have been reduced by 5% and investment by almost 20%. However,
despite its this investment in renewables has grown,
it is estimated that by 2020 alone,
198 gigawatts of renewable capacity will have been installed and almost 90%
increase in the entire global energy capacity. Yep. That's what I said 19%.
For example, if we look at electricity,
renewable sources already account for 27% of all production globally.
That's not all the international energy agency expects that in the next five
years alone, electricity production from renewable energy grow by another 50% to
9,745 terawatt hours.
The equivalent of the combined current demand of China and the entire European
union.
This is an expectation that is consistent with the trends of recent years.
Friends.
Some simply amazing numbers.
The international energy agencies forecast is that renewables will cover 99%.
Yes, that's right.
99% of the entire increase in global electricity demand over the period,
2020 to 2025. And this is no pie in the sky.
Either most projects are already planned or are in the research phase.
You don't have to dig too deep to see that many energy multinationals have
announced investments of tens and tens of billions in renewable.
Simply.
We are facing a historic change and it's not just about electricity generation
today. The importance of renewable energies is also going to grow stronger.
And the other two energy uses heat generation. And of course, transport,
surely you have all seen news. Yeah.
Yes.
Having come this far, I am sure, absolutely sure that there is a question.
Many of you are asking yourselves. I am certainly asking myself this question.
What on earth could explain this almost disruptive change that has begun to take
place over the last few years? Why are renewables growing so strongly?
And the ideas well, listen up because the answer may surprise. Many of them.
[Inaudible].
Tom, renewable energies.
Why are so many multinationals concentrating their investments in this sector?
Is it just a matter of following the guidelines set by politicians or agreements
like the one in Paris? Or is there something else? Isn't it strange?
Even countries like China have joined this kind of.
Trent.
Yes. Okay. Environmental awareness, social concern, responsibility,
all of that friends is all well and good,
but let's not fool ourselves in order to carry out a change, a transition,
a revolution that means transforming the entire model of world energy
production. Something else is needed. Energy needs to be competitive,
the cost and the profit and loss account all need to balance that.
Watch.
May surprise you, but that's exactly what's happening.
What we are going to show you next is not a green argument or anything like
that. This is visual politic.
What we're going to show you is nothing but the numbers,
the raw reality of the data friends over the last decade.
If we look at both the construction of production plants, for example,
a natural gas combined cycle power plant, or a wind farm,
and at the use fuel and operations themselves.
What we find is that the costs of renewable energy.
Plummeted.
These are the facts to take away.
The cost of onshore wind energy has fallen by 70% and the cost of solar energy
by almost 90%. And that's without counting subsidies of any kind today.
This is already a fact for new projects,
onshore wind and solar energy are on average,
much cheaper than energy from coal or natural gas.
And that is precisely why the vast majority of new electricity production
capacity is renewable.
Yeah.
There are other reports that calculate the cost of nuclear energy, even lover,
but renewable was still competitive. Anyway,
we'll talk about that in a future video. The fact is that as you can see,
just a decade ago,
every megawatt hour produced in a solar photovoltaics plant cost three
times as much as one produced in a coal-fired power plant today,
the cost of a solar megawatt hour is less than half of that, of coal.
As long as we're talking about new plants, of course, if, for example,
you already have a gas plant built then during its lifetime,
the production costs for gas will obviously be almost certainly.
[Inaudible].
Start from scratch. Then it's a different story. In fact, new photovoltaics,
solar energy installations are beginning to have costs that place them among the
cheapest energy sources in history. And the same could be said of wind energy.
Not only that, the estimate is that over the next few years,
the cost of this energy will continue to fall sharply. So the question,
the big question we can ask ourselves is how on earth has this been possible?
Well, different visual politic.
This has to do with the characteristics of each production system.
Let me explain while the cost of electricity generated by fossil fuels depends
largely on the price of the fuel itself, gas, oil, or coal, for example,
the same does not apply to renewable energy
In the case of wind or solar energy,
their cost is almost entirely linked to the cost of the technology and what the
price of the technology. Well,
the story is very similar to what happened with microchips cell phones or data
that production costs fall. As the technology develops the combined experience,
the accumulation of technological advances,
the small changes that increase efficiency.
It is a song of elements that in the end makes technology more and more
accessible. For example,
existing data and studies show that every time the installed solar capacity has
doubled, there has been a 36% drop in costs. In the case of onshore wind energy,
the figure has been 20%. And in the case of offshore wind energy,
10% take a look fast.
Although electricity produced from coal has historically been cheap compared to
photovoltaics solar energy. It is becoming relatively more expensive. Why? Well,
because in addition to the fact that the technology is already highly refined,
the cost of coal is a weighty factor. In fact,
coal accounts for about 40% of the total costs of a coal fired power plant.
And this my friends is what explains,
why renewables have become the stars of the energy world.
And that that is a change that not even the president of the United States can
stop.
[Inaudible].
So what I can say is this is fantastic news. On the one hand,
we're talking about a much cheaper energy and that in itself means more
prosperity and a better quality of life for.
Everyone.
Take note.
Because that's not the only benefit, the progressive replacement of energy,
especially coal plants by renewable energy ones will also reduce carbon dioxide,
emissions and pollution of all kinds.
And that's could prevent the loss of hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
lives, millions even each year. Yes, that's right.
International organizations estimate that between five and 8 million people die
every year.
Pollution.
You see renewable seem like good news that opened the door to a very hopeful
future cleaner and cheaper energy. What more could you ask for,
of course not everything is so beautiful.
There are still issues that need to be resolved such as the reliability of these
technologies.
What happens if the sun doesn't shine or the wind doesn't blow so far,
renewable energies need a backup structure that in many cases is hardly ever
used, but it has to be paid for nonetheless,
we have not included this cost if we had done so renewables will still be
competitive, somewhat less. So, but with a tendency towards decreasing costs,
however,
perhaps this can be resolved with the future development of macro energy storage
systems, or perhaps this technology will always have to co-exist with others,
but in any case, replacing coal with solar, for example, well, what can I say?
It seems like fantastic news.
In fact.
Do you know who is betting heavily, very heavily. In fact,
on photovoltaics solar energy, you'll be amazed.
The Petro monarchies of the past.
Golf.
In short, my friends,
these are the key components to today's global energy system.
I think you have a better understanding of the renewable energy revolution that
has been set in motion over the past few years.
The question the million dollar question is will we all soon enjoy increased
access to much cheaper energy or will our politicians savagely tax it so that
nothing changes. Leave your answers in the comments before.
Finish. We can end this video without wishing you all the best for the holidays.
Even though we already know this, probably won't be anyone's best holiday ever.
We also want to pass on our deepest condolences to every one of you who has lost
an important person during this pandemic. But despite all of that,
the whole team here at visual politics wants to wish you all a happy holidays.
I've got my whiskey as a Scotsman. That means main well-being so cheers,
Merry Christmas, and we'll see you next day.